coup de tonnerre ce matin mesdames et
messieurs c'était une grosse nouvelle
qui tombait autour de 10 heures sophie
Brochu président directrice générale
d'Hydro-Québec n'allait pas terminer son
mandat et elle est quitter dans quelques
semaines donc deux ans avant la fin de
son mandat elle démissionne c'est un des
postes le plus important au Québec après
le premier ministre des Finances Venise
l'économie la grande patronne
d'Hydro-Québec emmène large est une
grosse entreprise vous le savez
importante pour tous les Québécois elle
est avec nous sophie Brochu bonsoir
bonsoir Monsieur alors première question
toute simple pourquoi vous n'allez pas
au bout de votre mandat
en fait c'est assez fascinant parce que
je vois que les gens accrochent beaucoup
sur une durée de mandat qui est un
chiffre un nombre de mois
[Musique]
construire la maison que l'architecte
les équipes on a décidé moi ma force mon
talent c'est un talent d'architecture je
dessine des plans travailler avec un
client ou des clients nos clients c'est
quoi c'est la société québécoise c'est
vous c'est moi c'est le gouvernement
c'est tout le monde puis moi mon talent
c'est d'être l'architecte des plantes
après s'il y a des gens qui doivent
exécuter le plan et c'est très difficile
c'est très exige un autre talent et donc
le temps est propice pour moi mais
n'empêche respectueusement mon tour je
vous souligne madame Brochu qui forme
monter 30 ans en arrière pour voir un
mandat si court pour un PDG
d'Hydro-Québec habituellement c'est 5 ou
9 ans 8 ans c'est exceptionnel et que
vous n'alliez pas à la fin
sachant que la présidente du conseil
quitte également cet été à quel moment
avez-vous pris cette décision là d'abord
j'ai pris ma décision durant le congé de
Noël et après
après la tempête mais ça a rien à voir
mais je vous dirais que j'ai pris ma
décision si vous quoi après la tenue du
premier comité des priorités qui a été
mis sur place par Monsieur le Président
vous allez me dire c'est quoi le rapport
le rapport c'est que d'abord ce
comité-là regroupe le ministre des
Finances le ministre de l'Environnement
le ministre des Affaires autochtones le
ministre l'économie puis d'énergie et un
siège pour hydro que j'occupais que
j'occupe encore jusqu'en avril et j'ai
été à même de constater je rentrerai pas
dans la confidentialité des
conversations mais cette gouvernance là
qui a été mise en place pour mettre
toutes les voix autour de la table de
grande décision quant au futur
utilisation de l'électricité ma foi j'ai
vu que ça fonctionne la parole est libre
alors je quitte sereine que la
gouvernance que monsieur Legault a mis
en place pour fonctionne ok là vous
allez me dire faut que ça tienne et vous
avez raison mais je quitte donc parce
que le temps est bon contenu de ce que
j'ai accompli et compte tenu de ce qui
non seulement madame Bochu vous dites je
quitte pas parce que je m'entends pas
avec Monsieur faitgaben sur la vision
générale du développement d'Hydro-Québec
on le sait vous aviez des divergences
philosophiques vous vous êtes plutôt si
on veut simplifier de l'école il faut
qu'on soit plus efficace énergétiquement
avant d'entreprendre d'une augmentation
de notre capacité des nouveaux barrages
et Monsieur faitgaben pour simplifier
veut amener des clients qui vont acheter
beaucoup d'électricité pour développer
l'économie du Québec il y a quand même
deux visions qui s'affrontaient il y a
encore de visions qui sont là madame
brochute n'est-ce pas
il y a plus que deux visions puis je
vous dirais que écoutez sur 90 95% de
toutes les points de conversation que le
gouvernement puis Hydro-Québec là on
s'entend très bien d'ailleurs si vous
regardez depuis la domination du nouveau
ministre on a accompli plein de choses
ensemble il y a des décrets qui sont
sortis que ce soit quant à l'utilisation
des blocs de 50 MW et plus donc on
s'entend sur beaucoup de choses après ça
là il faut comprendre aussi qu'il y a il
existe et c'est très sain et c'est
nécessaire une certaine tension normale
entre le gouvernement Hydro-Québec et si
c'était pas le coffre franchement c'est
parce qu'on n'aurait pas de coup
d'inverse on serait mort c'est chacun à
son mandat et les visions qui sont mises
ce qui est pas ce qui est important
c'est pas mal
compatible madame rocher c'est ça parce
que là vous quittez quand même deux ans
avant je le répète vous dites j'ai fait
beaucoup de choses c'est vrai mais vous
quittez quand même deux ans avant est-ce
que votre vision était compatible avec
celle du gouvernement de monsieur
Legault
ma vision est compatible avec le tour de
table du comité des priorités en ce sens
que ma vision c'est celle où on a une
entité qui est capable de regarder
l'ensemble des des éléments du dossier
hydroélectrique que ce soit autochtone
environnementale économie et je vous
dirai finance puis le ministre des
Finances aussi à table alors on a autour
de la table des points de vue qui sont
complémentaires qui ajoutent à la
décision est prise et c'est ça qui est
important c'est pas que monsieur fait
Duben et moi ont pu savoir des
divergences sur une
des choses peuvent exister mais c'est
pour ça qu'il fait que je quitte en fait
je vous dirais même si c'était ça je
resterai si c'était juste ça et que je
pensais qu'avec quelque chose qui
marchait pas je me battrai à mort ok
vous me dites au téléspectateur que vous
partez parce que vous êtes arrivés à la
conclusion que tout va bien avec le
gouvernement le goût
en fait je suis en train de dire que
j'ai accompli beaucoup le timing est bon
parce que là on entre dans la phase
d'exécution du plan stratégique que la
situation financière de l'organisation
ici au plan des cycles des changements
dirigeants c'est simple et je pars le
cœur Serein parce qu'il y a une
gouvernance qui a été mise en place pour
s'assurer que les décisions soient
éclairées lorsque sont prises alors je
pense à dire que c'est facile puis que
tout allait bien et puis tout seul il va
y avoir ces tensions là autour de la
table mais à tout le moins ce n'est pas
une vision d'un ministre aussi
intelligent soit-il avec beaucoup de
pouvoirs qui peut prendre une direction
in abstracto d'enjeux plus globaux qui
me suivent le comprend lui-même puis il
le dit c'est un ensemble de décisions et
comme il vous le disait
un espace de dialogue avec le
gouvernement dans ce comité-là où vous
siégeait que Monsieur faitgaben monsieur
Legault qui préside etc pourquoi alors
ne pas aller au bout de votre mandat de
5 ans malgré tout vous avez quand même
été engagé pour cinq ans parce qu'on est
quand même dans une dans un moment
stratégique pour Hydro-Québec pourquoi
pas faire une ou deux années de plus
madame Brochu
parce que encore une fois on regarde ça
à travers la languette d'un mandat avec
un certain nombre de mois moi je regarde
ça avec la languette du dirigeant de
l'organisation qui dit voici ce qu'on a
accompli à date voici où on se trouve
puis voici ce qui s'en vient puisqu'il
va débuter dans les prochains mois va
porter sur beaucoup plus que deux ans et
à ce stade-ci il est il est sain contenu
que le reste est que la maison est à
l'ordre il est sain d'avoir quelqu'un
qui viennent prendre ça puis quand ton
garçon se dit mon dieu ça fait beaucoup
la présidente du conseil
d'administration la présidente de
l'organisation mais c'est aussi une
opportunité c'est une opportunité
d'avoir le temps de travailler à la
suite donc ce n'est pas vous ne dites
pas au gouvernement ou un monsieur le
gouv vous ne l'avez pas dit mais sur le
goût je respecte votre vision de la du
développement économique mais moi j'ai
pas tout à fait à l'aise avec ça donc
j'aime mieux que vous choisissiez
quelqu'un avec qui vous allez mieux vous
entendre de A à Z sur vert où on veut
amener ce minimum bateau
Hydro-Québec c'est pas ça
monsieur le Gaulle hier une très bonne
conversation j'ai dit monsieur Legault
d'abord merci de m'avoir donné cette
opportunité là extraordinaire c'est une
méchante job là c'est du 24/7 c'est vous
là mais intellectuellement c'est
extraordinairement stimulant et c'est un
privilège que je lui ai dit c'est que je
pars contenu de tout ce que je vous ai
dit puisque c'est un bon timing et le
cœur Serein parce que j'ai observé le
comité qu'il a mis en place la
gouvernance qu'il a mis en place qui à
mon sens venait répondre à la
préoccupation que j'avais évoquée mais
quand j'ai entendu tout le monde donner
son point de vue je me suis dit ce truc
là fonctionne la parole est libre et là
la décision va être éclairée après je
vais voir quelqu'un d'autre Hydro-Québec
qui va porter la voix d'Hydro-Québec
puis écoutez il y a une équipe de
direction qui est très costaud qui
d'ailleurs est en interaction à peu près
quotidienne avec le gouvernement du
Québec
parce que vous dites j'ai réussi à créer
un comité à demander au Premier ministre
un comité j'ai reçu ce comité là j'ai eu
des assurances mais savez-vous je m'en
vais quand même
en fait en fait ce que j'ai dit j'ai dit
ça prend une gouvernance la réponse de
Monsieur Lego ça a été dire je vais
mettre ce gros plan en place puis il va
y avoir la table puis la voix
d'Hydro-Québec alors si je resterai pas
chez Hydro-Québec pendant 100 ans là un
moment donné il faut et il faut prendre
une décision il faut prendre une
décision en fonction de le personnel
puis du cycle de l'organisation ce que
je vous dis là c'est que c'est pas une
décision politique est-ce que j'exprime
des vues qui sont les miennes la réponse
est oui puisqu'on celle d'Hydro mais
hydro a pas la science infuse mais quand
je regarde autour de table que j'entends
le ministre des Finances le ministre
l'environnement qui parle de son
transport le ministre l'économique qui
parle de ces industries le ministre des
Affaires pour bien faire les choses j'ai
confiance dans la mécanique et le
Premier ministre a mis en place est-ce
que vous avez un autre emploi en vue
je veux pas faire plus d'argent je me
remets dans la même position que j'ai
été quand on m'a appelé quand on m'a
appelé ça faisait trois mois que j'avais
quitté NRJ je l'avais annoncé je
débutais une sabbatique qui devait durer
deux ans j'ai été interpellé parmi je
suis venu mettre ma petite épaule à
cette grande roulotte ça a été
extraordinaire c'est c'est un
enrichissement inouï personnel et je
quitte parce que le plan est là c'est le
plan des Québécois les hydro-québecois
je trouve quebecoise sont ils
connaissent leur métier comme ça je peux
pas ils vont le livrer et ce que ce que
j'aime le plus de tout ce qu'on entend
depuis quelques temps c'est que il y a
un regain d'intérêt pour la conversation
sur la chose énergétique et ça c'est un
peu important le point de vue qu'on a je
dois vous laisser aller bientôt mais
est-ce que vous fermez la porte à une
entrée à une carrière politique
absolument je la ferme pas je l'emburre
il y a des gens qui restent de vous au
PLQ ailleurs vous étiez non jamais
jamais
j'ai pas d'appétit pour ça j'ai beaucoup
de respect pour tout ce qu'ils font mais
j'ai pas d'appétit pour cette joute là
je n'ai pas la peau de crocodile que
Madeleine Albright avait
normalement on a vu puis on l'a vu avec
vos désaccord avec Monsieur faitgaben on
a vu que vous vous étiez capable de vous
battre vous saviez vous venez de le dire
je j'aurais aimé et je suis carré d'un
battre jusqu'au bout quand je pense que
quelque chose est doit être fait
je comprends qu'elle ajoute politique
tout le monde essaie de voir le désavu
de nécessaire
d'être venu nous parler en direct à la
prochaine au revoir vous restez jusqu'au
mois d'avril je le souligne merci au
revoir merci monsieur